Vince colonies is a radio host in
Washington DC a very popular one
deserveably so and he joins us tonight
to assess NPR now you live in Washington
you report on it on the radio
um was there ever a question in your
mind that this was State media
not at all my our mutual buddy Chris
Plante calls them National panhandler
radio appropriately uh NPR and you know
what's amazing about this they're trying
to prove that they're not State media
and they're relying on everyone who's
funded by the state in order to make
that defense so Kareem Jean-Pierre
stands there at the White House Press
briefing and says NPR is so independent
she gives a brave heart style speech to
attesting to their independence do you
think she would ever do that for Simon
attiba like not not in a million years
not in a million years of course it's
for NPR NPR cited Joel Roth the former
head of censorship at Twitter as a guy
who said they shouldn't be labeled State
Affiliated media Joel Roth and Twitter
at the time were making millions of
dollars from the federal government to
censor the American public these are all
completely biased people and and one
last big thing that I noticed about this
Tucker they say in all of their defenses
well only one percent of our funding
less than one percent comes from the
federal government even that is
deception even that is a lie NPR is a
kind intent organization the Thousand
member stations that they send content
to all pay fees to NPR guess where they
get their money from that's right the
federal state and local governments as
much as 23 percent of all of their
funding comes from there we're talking
hundreds of millions of dollars and here
they are playing a shell game and the
only type of organization that plays
that that kind of deceptive shell game
not a news organization uh one that is
running a political operation on behalf
of the government it's totally right NPR
is repulsive but not quite as repulsive
as its listeners the most privileged
people in the world demanding welfare
from the rest of us Vince colonies who
was on Commercial radio not working for
the state appreciate seeing you tonight
thank you subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight